you sent letterman the piece of the
stage where he stood every night and did
his monologue as far as i can tell as a
gift yeah that was very thoughtful was
that your idea when we were remodeling i
came in to look around and say well
where would i want to stand yeah because
that's it's really important and i have
my own
desire of where i like to stand on stage
normally you're very close to the
audience i notice you move very far
upstate i like to be close to the
audience yeah i like how you move around
on the camera too i like how you walk
out of frame yeah well john harrison who
has been my
number two camera for a long time his he
knows that he knows not to fight don't
ever follow me it's good i just like the
frame right i just like i love that so i
go out there and i walk out on stage and
they're just tearing [ __ ] down around me
and i walk out and i go where would i
want to stand right there were some
boxes on stage and i said could you move
these boxes yeah so they moved the boxes
and i stood in the spot where the boxes
had been and i went yes feels right this
feels like the right place to stand and
i looked down and between my feet i was
standing on dave's spot oh like an
accident x marks the spot red dot no
kidding i'm standing on that spot and i
went oh of course this is where you'd
want to stand
of course there's no dummy this is where
you'd want to start but why that spot
you're close enough that you can feel
the audience but you're far enough back
in that room specifically that you can
play to the balcony because you've got
to be able to be far enough back to see
the balcony too you got to feel both of
them and when you realize that was
dave's spot you said aha i'm going to
cut the floor i said please just
preserve this tile because it's all
marley that floor it's a it's one big
square it's about this big yeah and his
stage was blue mine's black it was a c
blue and uh with a red dot on it and so
i had it taken out edit cleaned
and and then i put it in a frame and
everybody would come into my office and
say what do you think that is and they
go is that an ellsworth kelly whatever
it looks like a very famous piece
because it's
minimalist art it's a beautiful blue
shiny backdrop with just one red dot in
the corner and you could read a lot into
what that could possibly be sure and i
didn't hang it up and i didn't hang it
up and i didn't hang it up and i'd had
it for i don't know almost a year and
i'm like why aren't i hanging this up
and i went cause it's not yours dummy
yeah and so i sent it to dave last year
and just said i i i think you'll know
people don't know what this is when they
walk in my office i think you might
that's what i said i think you should
have it did he write you back he wrote
me a lovely little note thank you and he
liked it i bet it was hard to part with
because that's television history it
sure is yeah did you keep any props from
the colbert report did you ever say oh
i'm sentimental about where i sat or my
chair or anything like that i kept the
captain america shield right we had
captain america shield because years and
years ago when captain america was
killed in the book version of uh civil
wars right he's assassinated and so they
they read i got a i got a letter from
joe casada who's the who was the
managing editor of marvel and and i got
a big box and a letter and the letter
said we read cap's uh
will yes and he said that you were the
only person patriotic enough to handle
the solid vibranium shield so they sent
me the shield that literally had been
hanging on marvel's wall since the six
oh you're kidding that's the actual
shield they had in marvel studios or
marvel headquarters
and uh my wife who doesn't know anything
about uh comic books or superheroes she
read the letter and she said um with
tears in her eyes she goes i don't know
what any of this means but i'm so proud
of you